Rory Stewart is running or perhaps
walking as an independent candidates to
be Mayor of London and he joins us in
the studio it's just you're very good to
see you this morning what on earth are
you doing haven't you had enough of
politics isn't it time to put your feet
up on the farm and and enjoy the finer
things in life
well I one of the reasons I'm doing it
is that I don't like party politics but
I do think one of the great ways to
engage help and support people is
locally and I think the exciting thing
about being a mayor of a city is it's
very practical and you can focus on one
of the things I like about it is that
when I'm on the tube people can come up
poke you in the chest and say what's
gone wrong on the signalling of the
Piccadilly line or you can be out on the
streets and people can challenge you on
policing and then it's your
responsibility and it's something you
can help to sort out whereas with an MP
you're very distant in that talking shop
so what is the pitch down trap for a
city home if you can surmise it in 30
seconds get the basic foundations right
in order to make an amazing city London
isn't safe enough we can make it safe
we've got to get the affordable housing
and we've got to get the transport right
and once you've got those foundations in
place then you can build to have all
those spectacular things we need so
you're clearly your from a well Kent
Scottish family well travelled spent a
lot of time in Indonesia Afghanistan
Iraq of course MP for a seat in Cumbria
and no one ought to assume your kind of
korah blimey governor apples and pears
you know you're a Londoner at heart are
you I think the key thing about London
is that London is the most diverse city
on earth mm-hmm
2011 38 percent of people in London
we're not born in the United Kingdom
I wasn't born in the United Kingdom Hong
Kong was born in Hong Kong yeah and I
think London is a great international
city I speak eight or nine languages
quite badly it's something to be proud
of and I think that I can bring the
experience of what I did in Iraq or
Afghanistan to thinking about security
and safety I can bring the experience of
turning around prisons when I was
presence Minister to policing in London
and I'm lucky enough still to be in the
same house I was in in South Carolina
was baby so I have a long history in
London to see my producer has been using
this line a few times this morning so
I'm going to do I mean Rory sure you're
not JFK
you're rather more Michael Palin
aren't you if you're walking towards and
all the rest of it and actually in
sometimes for someone who displayed a
sensitivity during the conservative
leadership election that many people
picked up on there were other points at
which you frankly didn't you met three
young men and when you were out doing
your walking - and you there was a
remarkable quote that you gave one thing
about social media is that it allows
people to see politicians listening I
can go to Brick Lane and three sort of
minor gangsters can come up to me and
spend a minute telling me I'm an idiot I
mean they weren't gangsters and they
also weren't British they were Irish
when it mean there's a there is a
sensitivity that comes from having lived
in a city for a length of time that that
doesn't demonstrate so you're absolutely
right
I apologized immediately when that came
out and I completely understand why that
caused offense and I think they had come
up to me like heartily they were teasing
me
and I completely understand they can do
that I should not I shouldn't have said
that and I think politicians and I've
done this twice in my career in ten
years need to be careful what they say
and I was wrong to say that can we be
absolutely clear where does the money
coming from for your campaign you don't
have a big party backing are you funding
this yourself and you have a staff at
the moment yes I have to raise all the
money and that comes partly from crowd
funding so I'm getting hundreds of
smaller donations and then I have to go
around getting larger donations from
people what percentage of the donations
are coming you know from small donations
what percentage from larger organ of
presumed ibly organizations banks
businesses so on at the moment it's
pretty balanced but all of that is
something that we will be publishing in
line with other parties and you'll be
able to compare me against Sadiq Khan
and the conservative candidates and
others because I believe in transparency
so we will publish in the same way that
other parties do you are making a huge
play about the crime that Londoners are
experiencing at the moment what is your
solution to a problem that frankly
successive mayors in successive
commissioners have failed to deal with I
think I would do very much what I did as
prisons Minister so when I came in as
prisons when some violence had tripled
in five years in prisons many people
said it couldn't be turned around for a
difficult situation I promised to resign
unless I brought that violence down we
put the uniformed officers in the
landings we got the data behind them
we reduced
in prisons by 16% in seven months I take
the same approach to policing in London
I would triple the number of uniformed
police in the neighbourhoods I'd put the
data behind them to make sure that they
were in the right places at the right
time and I would put an absolute focus
on the question of reducing violence
street crime priorities essentials
policing all of this so it sounds
expensive min Sadiq Khan is talking
about an increase in council tightening
its what 11 Prime's 56 a month more for
the average londoner
for you would it be the same is it is it
gonna have to be council tax rises yes
Sadiq is right to do that but my
question is why is it only when I've
announced my police plan and said I'm
gonna put extra police on the streets
that he suddenly said that he has the
money to do it mmm why didn't he do it
last year why didn't he do it two years
ago why didn't he do it three years ago
we need uniformed police on the streets
we should triple the number uniformed
police in streets some of that will come
from the home office some of that we can
provide from the map but it's about
getting the front line all good policing
begins with communities if you don't
have the communities the information
will take you straight back to your
voting record as an MP you voted for the
cuts to policing you voted for the cuts
to preventative services you voted for
the cuts for youth clubs mental health
services and so on you're a minister and
a Conservative government that you know
prosecuted a strategy of austerity how
can you know while standing for Mayor of
London talk about the fact that these
things need to be sorted out when do you
were part of the problem so I absolutely
agreed that we were spending a hundred
billion pounds more than we were taking
in revenue and the country was getting
towards the state of bankruptcy we
needed to reduce but when I was the
president's minister I acknowledged that
too many prison officers been cut I
brought four thousand five hundred extra
prison officers back onto those landings
I also as prisons Minister Rhee
nationalized the privatized probation
servicing as a conservative minister I'd
been pushing a lot on this and remember
a lot of this is in the hands the map
the mare often talks as though he's
powerless he's got a budget bigger than
the budget of the GDP of 76 countries
yeah and Sadiq Ana's just proved that he
could have put more police on the
streets and he chose not to many people
assume that you are where I should say
on the kind of the more liberal
libertarian wing of the conservative
party what then is your view
of the facial recognition technology
that Scotland Yard is ruling out would
you permit that if you have a maid of
London yes I would I think facial
recognition technology is a very very
important tool i pioneered it actually
and what we were doing in prisons even
it led to a many many more arrests for
people bringing drugs you don't see as a
massive land grab in terms of civil
liberties I think they are challenges
about how you use it how you manage that
data and that is also true of CCTV
cameras it's an extension of what we're
already doing with CCTV cameras on the
streets but we must make London safer
the homicide rate is the highest rate
it's been for 11 years and it's not just
that that's muggings that's a curfew you
could arm every police officer these
would be measures that you wouldn't do
because they weren't recording the
concern about facial recognition
technology is that similarly it is
draconian so in anything it's all about
balance I think we should be very proud
that our police officers are not all
armed
we're should be very proud that our
firearms officers are highly trained
people and we shouldn't be going over to
a curfew I've imposed curfews in places
like Iraq I wouldn't be doing that here
in London but I think facial recognition
technology is a the right thing to do I
think tasers in the right place the
right thing to do but above all it's
about relationships it's about having
the police out meeting the communities
knowing who to deal with that's how you
deal with this you surround stop and
search going wrong that's how you get
the information that's how you make
places safe visible presence can I take
you back to your to your decision to
resign from cabinet and and ultimately
of course to step down from the
Parliament was that a mistake I mean
it's not beyond the realms of
comprehension right now to terms of
probability I should say right now that
you could be currently in a Boris
Johnson cabinet in a relatively senior
post I would much much rather be an
independent than running to be Mayor of
London than be sitting in a Conservative
cabinet the moment there is so much to
be done in London and one of the reasons
for that is I'm somebody who's never
been comfortable in political parties I
believe that actually for people like me
who think that we should take ideas from
the right and the left city politics is
where you want to be because
city politics all over the world
independent candidates in New York all
over the world it's the cities that are
pragmatic you can't be ideological about
clearing your rubbish Marx doesn't have
very much save and the signalling on the
Piccadilly line so I want to be about
action getting away from politics to
action I cannot let you go without
mentioning the fact that of course
last night was burns night I had to give
it a Miss because it was in the office
at half past 4:00 this morning I'm
wondering if you were out and about
whether indeed you have a have a
favorite have a favourite piece of Burns
poetry well I think my father kept here
doing some hay meat but can I eat to us
every night but for me in London it's
about embracing the Scottish community
London is the third largest Scottish
population on earth but it's embracing
other communities too so I was out
yesterday and Brent looking at some very
very difficult housing and I actually
spent a lot of a lot of burns night with
the Afghan community which I was very
proud to do but I haven't yet worked out
how to translate some hay meat into dari
well I'm from ear when there are
tonestar classes for honest men and
bonny lassies honest man what we'll find
out Kampala did what we brought Easter
thank you very much very much